hello and welcome to med simplified
while coronavirus cases continue to soar
across the world
we have another reason to worry the
emergence of bird flu
after many states in india reported
death of birds mostly non-domesticated
bird flu or avian influenza was
confirmed in kerala
rajasthan madhya pradesh haryana
and himachal pradesh high alert has also
been sounded in maharashtra
several states which have been reporting
deaths of birds including crows and
migratory species
are scrambling to have samples tested
for the virus
similar incidents were reported in
countries like japan
china south korea netherlands uk
belgium denmark france and many more
countries
the sudden drop in demand in prices is
compounding the losses of millions of
small poultry farmers
in an industry that only recently
started to recover
from the covet outbreak that hugely
impacted sales during 2020.
avian influenza also called avian flu or
bird flu
is an illness that usually only affects
birds
there are many different strains of bird
flu virus but the most commonly seen
and most deadly form of the virus is
called influenza
a or the h5n1 virus
the last time avian influenza hit india
in 2006
it seriously disrupted the functioning
of poultry industry
the government intervened first
confirming the presence of the bird flu
and then destroying numerous birds to
control the spread of the virus
so in this video we will talk about what
is bird flu
the virus that causes bird flu we will
discuss
whether this disease can spread from
human to human and whether you should
stop
eating poultry right now or not
bird flu also known as avian influenza
or avian flu
is a variety of influenza caused mostly
by the group a
influenza viruses so influenza viruses
are a type of
rna viruses and they can be divided into
four main groups
influenza a influenza b influenza c
and influenza type d viruses influenza
a-type viruses usually infect wild
aquatic birds
and often spread to poultry birds
causing bird flu
and can spread to humans also we will
discuss more about the type a viruses
later
influenza b viruses almost exclusively
infect humans
whereas influenza c viruses infect
humans
dogs pigs sometimes causing
both severe illness and local epidemics
now let's
look at how these viruses damage living
organisms
now influenza virus can only replicate
inside a living cell
first the virus binds to the surface of
the cell and injects
its genetic material which in this case
is a viruses rna
inside the living cell then the genetic
material of the virus
takes over the molecular machinery of
our living cells
and instructs ourselves to make more
copies of the viruses genetic material
slowly the cell gets filled with the
viral rna and dies
the viral rna then assembles a membrane
over it
and in the last it exits the host cell
the current epidemic of avian influenza
is caused by the h5 and
8 strain of the influenza a virus before
this
mostly the h5n1 strain of the virus has
led to most epidemics among the birds
while h5n8 presents only a low risk to
humans
it is highly lethal to wild birds and
poultry
in india several states have reported
positive tests for avian influenza
among poultry and many types of
non-domesticated birds also
among these states kerala is the most
affected
as per the kerala government over 69 000
birds including ducks and chickens were
curled and eggs have also been destroyed
in some districts to contain the spread
of h5n8 strain of the bird flu
the northern state of himachal pradesh
reported the death of more than 3000
birds
from the disease mostly bar-headed geese
at a wildlife sanctuary
in india the disease spread mostly
through migratory birds
entering the country during the winter
season
the avian influenza virus can jump from
species to species and
infect humans from an infected bird the
first case of infection in humans was
reported in hong kong
in 1997 when a poultry farm worker
caught the infection from infected birds
human infections have been reported only
among people
who are poultry handlers and people who
deal with the sale of live animals
the high mortality rate in humans almost
60 percent
is the main cause of concern about the
spread of bird flow
so it is very important that you take
all possible precautions while the
outbreak lasts
people with co-morbidities or aged above
65 are the most vulnerable
pregnant women infants aged below 2 are
also vulnerable to the infection
the common symptoms of bird flow in
humans are
runny nose sneezing or sore throat in
the initial stages
while in the later stages the virus can
cause fever
fatigue body pain chills dry cough
and headaches now let's look at some of
the precautions you should take
regarding this avoid consuming uncooked
or partially cooked eggs and chicken
cooking meat at high heat
can kill the virus avoid coming in
direct or close contact with infected
poultry
the virus can enter your body if you
touch your eyes
nose or mouth after touching the
infected bird
you can also get the virus if you touch
a surface contaminated with a bird's
excretions
such as their stools or saliva the virus
can also be transmitted from large
infected droplets in the air
when in close contact with the infected
bird
now let's answer the most important
question regarding bird flu
and that is should you stop eating
poultry and eggs right now
scientifically there is little evidence
to support the fact that bird flu can
spread to healthy people
via eggs and meat after thorough washing
and cooking
it is safe to eat them and they do not
act as a carrier of the virus
who has said the same whenever any meat
or poultry is exposed to heat
it kills any germs pathogens or viruses
which may be present on the surface or
even beneath it
hence cooking thoroughly makes it safer
for use
while cooking an egg make sure that the
yellow yolk becomes firm
and avoid eating runny eggs during the
course of this
outbreak this is also a precautionary
step
people should take before consuming any
type of non-veg food
according to experts a cooking
temperature of up to 70 degrees celsius
that reaches all the parts of eggs or
meat is good to kill germs
also make sure to buy the poultry from
organic trusted places
slaughtered meat or handling of dead or
diseased
birds before cooking should be strictly
avoided during this epidemic
lastly also remember that we are already
in the middle of a widespread pandemic
wash your hands with good quality soap
and water for 20-30 seconds before
and after cooking as long as you follow
good hand hygiene
take care of your source of poultry and
cook it well
there is really no reason to worry
so guys thank you so much for watching
this video
i hope you liked the video if you did
support us by hitting the like button
below
and you can also support math simplified
by clicking the join button below
or joining us on patreon page all links
are in the description box below
thank you so much for watching see you
in the next video